[Music]
my granddad was a soldier in the front
say 41
the boys took his brother
this double up held up the sky was fire
[Music]
millions lost in flames
hate and love are all there no one net
for the same days will sink and sadness
the weight of them - don't lose yourself
to madness
the way
[Music]
New York town worst crumble you're all
New York be still for a moment are just
human at the same old red and the wicked
I'll go once key me the power in the
pain but the heart the lungs the freedom
the fire though tea
des will sink and sadly in the way of
them too tough to lose yourself the
madness the way
[Music]
virus toka comfort
as never are still the enemy is inside
put together
I love this life is so damn fragile leaf
called with every breath and tragic
ignite eats a hole within days will sink
and sadness a weight of them to lose
yourself to madness the way is
[Music]
you